president trump clashing with the media
over wearing a mask
take a look well i did wear i had one on
before
i wore one in this back area but i
didn't want to give the press the
pleasure of seeing it
but no where i had it in the back area i
did put a basket
the media grilling trump on masks after
a new study finds that wearing one can
reduce coronavirus spread
by 75 percent and a shocking reversal
from the cdc is upending a key warning
about the spread of covid19
the government agency now saying the
virus does not spread easily on
contaminated surfaces and
is mainly transmitted through person to
person
contact all right dana let's just start
with the whole mask
deal from a communications perspective i
can understand why the president
doesn't want to give the media that
photograph
of him wearing a mask do you understand
why
i do but i also think that he wants
people to get back to work and one of
the best ways to get people back to work
and make them feel comfortable is to
wear people are going to have to wear
masks
or they're going to be asked to wear
masks private businesses are asking
people to wear a mask
i think the more that we make it a
stigma against wearing masks the worse
it will be and i think if he were to
wear a mask i don't care what the media
says
you know and i don't love wearing a mask
either but i think that if people were
willing to wear a mask and like hey this
is what we're doing we're protecting
ourselves we're protecting each other
and we
and we are getting back to work that if
you couple mask wearing with this new
cdc
information that it's person to person
and not on surfaces
you know if it's not on surfaces that
really does help business think about
okay maybe we can get people back to
work even sooner
um so i think that's all moving in the
right direction
i wouldn't worry so much about what the
media is going to say about wearing a
mask
if you want people to get back to work
give them some encouragement and tell
them to wear a mask
yeah greg and i mean can you believe now
it's not that
transmissible when the surface is
touched and i mean this
this is the main thing we heard very
early on and that's what people were
doing were spraying
everything we came in contact with
as a person who sleeps on a lot of
surfaces i feel
a great sense of relief look um there
was a story about surfaces
uh the viruses actually lived on the
surface for 18 hours do you remember the
press ran with that
and then it turned out when you when
listen to the experts
it wasn't the virus per se the active
component it was some like dormant
useless
leftover part of it but the media helps
pushing this
and in a weird way they push uh
organizations like the cdc into a corner
and doctors generally real doctors as
you've noticed with fauci and others are
very cautious about everything
because nothing is for sure and
everybody in this climate
has made a mistake everybody even me and
i know that's hard
to fathom but this is a new i know this
is it
once this is a new phenomenon and some
mistakes will kill people
we've seen that some decisions were
lucky there was a non-expert decision
to stop travel from a non-expert
president trump and it turned out the
experts had to admit
that he was right the cdc was initially
wrong on masks
because maybe they wanted to stop a run
on supplies
that's fine but it was still wrong
because even a crappy mask
if you make one yourself is still going
to reduce and create friction
a barrier between you and somebody else
i do understand though uh trump's
reluctance to hand the media a photo op
and i can't argue with him about media
because he hasn't been wrong
he hasn't been wrong on that
kind of like you greg hasn't been wrong
katie you know one of the reasons a lot
of people changed
some of the protocols early on and as
this thing develops is because
we didn't know a lot about this early on
because of china
china destroyed samples they didn't
communicate what they had found we had
to learn things a month later from our
allies in
europe and we're still learning more and
more about this today
well i just have to say for the record i
was the one stocking up on toilet paper
before anybody else
on the show and telling people to be
prepared so i will take that
as a win in the win category for kdp
um but on the issue of china of course
we've talked all about that
i do think that there is a huge
frustration
among the american people when they hear
these guidelines being changed just
because you know they they
are willing to give them the benefit of
the doubt they're willing to do the
15-day stop the spread the 30-day now
we're 60 days in
and what we were told about the way this
thing spreads
and the justification for not going to
work and losing businesses and jobs
is now different and i think people are
very frustrated between the media
and the changes in the mass policy and
the way
you know the the information that we're
getting they don't know what to trust
and where to get their information so
now people are like
well i've been told 50 different things
by the media and by the government
so i would just like to take my chances
and get back to work
yeah juan so if you think about the two
main things that we've now learned
recently sunlight really has a
detrimental effect on this virus being
outside
and if it's not as transmissible from
surface
that it looks like the main area of
transmission is really really close
human to human contact and i think that
should guide our policy going forward
sure and i think we're learning more as
we get more research and
and the doctors and the scientists can
reach stronger conclusions jesse i'm not
sure i would condem people for
uh you know what they said before what
they said now because i think we're all
in a learning process
in fact i think there's lots of good
people i'll condemn if i want to
speak i will condemn if i want
i i get that idea i know you so i i know
what i'm in
for uh but i was gonna say i think
there's lots of good news uh coming from
that scientific
expert community on the vaccines they're
making progress i think the rate
there's a decline in the rate of
infection all over the country
but there's certainly no arguing about
the fact that we're now approaching
a hundred thousand americans who will
have lost their lives that's a lot of
people jesse and you can understand
why they would try to tell us be
cautious you know and that when they
weren't sure about surfaces
watch out for surfaces i still think you
need to watch out it's not that you
should ignore surfaces
but the latest thing that catches my
attention is that now you see the
scientists and the doctors saying
watch out for the second wave and it's
not in new york
or any other big city but look in places
like maine and
iowa and oklahoma uh i saw just today
that the mayor of montgomery alabama
says his
his uh hospitals are overwhelmed they
have no more
beds for intensive care i think we've
all got to be cautious going forward
all right